i mean i i suppose every actress when
they like see themselves on screen
they're like oh they cut out my best
lines or october 2nd 2000 the day it all
began there was magic and chaos we're
talking shocking allergic reactions a
mortified young actor and paparazzi
worries
we've got exclusive raw footage from the
very first day magic was made and we can
confirm mischief was definitely managed
he shows up to set he cries on cue and
nails his first day in front of everyone
as the harry potter
you're a wizard harry
okay well it wasn't so simple as that
this touching final scene of the film
was the first to be shot and radcliffe
pulled out all the stops but not on
purpose ever notice that his eyes appear
blue in only this scene the crying
wasn't because of his skills radcliffe
was just having a really rough allergic
reaction to the contacts to change his
eye color at least it worked for the
shot
we're not allowed to do magic away from
hogwarts you know that
he was a young actor in a new major role
making odd choices was a given but the
shade's on set well this one was new but
hey let the actor do what he needs to do
right yeah i'm going to take my last
minute excellent if it works it works
but these glasses weren't a character
choice no one caught on to the fact that
little radcliffe might have had
something to hide and honestly it was
enjoyable for the crew to watch on as
the actor marked out his scenes
takes on a completely different
look with sunglasses the secret behind
the cool dude sunglasses
his eyes were so sensitive because of
the allergic reaction from the contacts
that little radcliffe was too
embarrassed to say anything and just
tried to hide it obviously he was
committed to his job from the very
beginning
[Music]
are you excited
just when we thought we couldn't love
emma watson anymore her excitement and
energy to be on the scene was adorable
and it's clear from the very start that
she really was hermione
little watson was also clearly ready to
handle all the media interviews and bts
moments to come do we think she knew how
much the camera loves her we feel you
emma we feel you
yeah my first day filming are you
excited i'm really excited i can't wait
to summon up the first day on set
bringing this magical world to the
screen well
watson says it best it feels absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
hey kid welcome to work would you mind
sitting on this broom rig and flying
high in the air for everyone to see
cool
okay so the crew probably went over some
safety measures and made sure matthew
lewis was safely rigged up but still
talk about an intense first day the
actor did his famous neville on a
broomstick sequence and really made a
splash riding on that chaotic rig while
it was definitely cool the young actor
was so far out of his comfort zone and
dove right into the deep end
gotta give him credit though he nailed
this terrified performance although
really he was probably just going method
and fully terrified no idea what to
expect you know i've never done anything
like that in my life
rupert grint so pretty with barrettes in
his hair
but don't let him hear it the adorable
actor's cheeks turned as red as his hair
when caught by the cameras preparing for
his very first day
if only he knew about the frilly dress
robes that were to come in a few years
his dainty barrettes made the actor
awfully nervous before he got to film
but once the hair and makeup team
finished and he felt like ron weasley
there was no stopping this firecracker
you go glen cocoa
filming massive scenes filled with magic
and a huge number of young actors many
of which have never experienced being on
a set before
well it's a pure recipe for disaster but
the hp squad made literal magic happen
after a couple of key lessons that is it
was one task to get the actors to
actually focus long enough to be able to
get a solid take but the real issue was
the fact that half of them didn't even
know what action meant chris columbus
and david yates had probably never run
into this issue before but eventually
they capture the shots this was one of
the many lessons learned and hurdles
that came with working with all these
young witches and wizards
while some actors weren't ready to go on
action radcliffe had the opposite
problem on his first big day of filming
the excitement of a new set is
definitely overwhelming but the harry
potter actor was jumping on his q's a
bit too quickly while it is important to
go on action
it's equally important not to go before
action is called it took a while but hey
for this iconic wave
totally worth it all right dan you'll be
waving as the train leaves this time
lean out just a little more
he may have been young but radcliffe was
no stranger to the realities of being an
actor after doing david copperfield and
he was on high alert what for
the paparazzi of course it was only his
first day but maybe somehow he knew just
how big a sensation he was going to
become
what do you do
can't get anything past you dan the
young actor knew both how to handle and
charm the press and everyone behind the
scenes of course
okay get back to work
people need to pamper you
[Music]
nervous while he'd been preparing to
play the role for a while and had
already been on set working for a couple
days for initial photography nothing
could prepare him for what it would be
like when the pressure was really on and
the movie was going full steam ahead on
the hogwarts express quite literally
fair play dan we would be too but
luckily he had a whole lot of support
behind him and a team ready to make
magic clearly the boy who lived does
well under pressure
[Music]
these number
one
from the outset the harry potter team
was determined to stay as true to the
books as they could but obviously some
changes had to be made what with
radcliffe's eyes watering with contacts
in and emma watson's inability to speak
clearly these are teeth number three and
i think these are the best
they may have been the best teeth but
they really weren't up to par
yeah all these fake teeth tried on
during her teeth test may have looked
pretty good but they made it real tough
for watson to sound as eloquent as she
does as hermione
it's leviosa not leviosa
and really what would we do without that
epic line a mumbling actress definitely
wasn't sustainable for eight films so
the teeth got the boot the best teeth of
all were much closer to home
[Music]
instead of going over lines or getting
worried about what he needed to film
radcliffe let his age show hanging out
and making small talk about the olympics
with the crew
guaranteed
yep it's good
calm cool and collected all while
charming and getting to know the people
that would become like his family and
watch him grow up i didn't really expect
to
to get emotional even though it was kind
of 10 years of my life
[Music]
she only had one scene but that didn't
stop the actress from totally reveling
in all the magic at just nine years old
little bonnie didn't understand what a
set was but she knew how to stand and be
adorable for the cameras and hey it
worked we wouldn't know it but the
littlest weasley was totally overwhelmed
and nervous and not just because she was
in the company of her future wizard
husband we're totally jealous of the
fact that in her very first job on set
she got to hang out with the dame julie
walters acting royalty much being on set
is a lot less intimidating with an
acting legend there to take you under
their wing especially one this feisty
do you want a bit of malarkey
a room full of smiling young actors
is there anything better for chris
columbus it probably would have been
this same room full of young actors but
actually focused instead of just
grinning ear to ear in awe what did he
expect though really
the group scenes were as hectic as you'd
imagine all while being perfectly
adorable as for the golden trio well
they weren't getting stellar grades just
yet since they hardly could get through
a scene without laughing or just getting
too distracted thank goodness the
editing team was well versed in cuts
since most of the movie had to be put
together line by line and shot by shot i
think everyone's a bit more
kind of relaxed really
imagine having to perform an epic role
as a young kid with hundreds of people
there to witness every moment and that's
a go on stage fright luckily little dan
managed it extremely well when it came
to his performance but behind that
lightning bolt scar and round glasses
the actor was jittering with nerves
solid work considering so many people on
set were curious and waiting to get
close to the young whiz
from day one grint was guilty of
laughing throughout scenes this was a
bad habit that wound up lasting the
entire franchise but in the early days
alan rickman decided to take little
grint under his wing a well-respected
actor by this point rickman had some
tricks up his sleeve
when it came to trying not to laugh
during a scene just try to rest your
face and keep your mind clear
this advice worked for the snape actor
but rupert
well
obviously not so much
so what we can conclude essentially is
that the first day on the harry potter
set was one of the most adorable in all
of movie making history who do you think
had the most intense first day
experience